physical early for the canes defenseman
Carolina will switch up and that'll give
an opportunity for Shay he'll hand it for NIS
trying to walk his way through the middle of
the rink he does he'll snap a shot R go Goran
had no idea and NIS gets Carolina off to the
hot start one- nothing hurricanes well he's
a one-man speed machine in the neutral zone
when he has the ability to rev it up a one-man
entry on the power play and that creates this
entry at five on five and then there's no such
thing as a bad shot at top speed and what the
goenda did gor have on the blocker side looking
for an outlet he plays it off the boards nobody
home for Carolina and a chance for Johansson set
up now A Chance in and that'll ring the PO po as
miles wood had the opportunity and that'll clink
out of play so an early look here for Carolina
as they can set up slaven to Burns a little one
touch pass Jarvis we fling it around the boards
terrain he'll go cross drop back to with the extra
attacker and Marty NES is having a night in the
first 6 minutes and 25 seconds two nothing nature
pass by T terrain and he's at the bottom of your
screen remember as soon as Colorado touches
the puck it's a whistle and a delayed penalty
he finds Burns I don't know how he saw way across
the rink and then Burns make a makes a delightful
pass drops it right into the Wheelhouse of NES and
blows it by gorgia trying to work that down indeep
here pass NIS bouncing Puck set by slaven he'll
find AO back to slaven he sh right on rebounds out
in front chance on they score here come the hats
a natural hatrick for Martin AIS three nothing
Carolina I don't know if the czechia born forward
has played an ounce of baseball in his life but a
natural hattrick in the first period in the top
of the first inning he should report to Spring
training T terrain had made a play in the neutral
zone about 15 seconds before denying a transition
pass from kale M like I said different types of
goals but all three goals well inside the dots
offensively two assists tonight for Terrain in a
natural hattrick now martinook will wave it one
and korv gets a piece second opportunity inside of
the net boy what a job there stacking up a couple
of times at your own Blue Line before Mar through
the call 20 seconds Carolina will be going on a
power play a little bit more time left on this
one but there's only 30 seconds left here in this
opening frame a little four on four now Maro gets
to it basic shot of score correction periz Zack
periz gets to this and a bouncing Puck and the
ABS on the board late here in the first periz this
is his third game as a Colorado avalan and Brady
shade tries to use the element of surprise to seal
the pass and it was really well played by Logan
oconor you know what I do here Mike I would have
played it differently if I was Shay because OK
Conor's on his backand much less threatening shot
he tried to surprise him and oh boy and now this
one's flung in from outside the blue line and that
gets through coach shov and Sam Gerard in this
one from outside the blue line and coov just muffs
it what concerned me against Vancouver
was that he had mental lapses in his game
started really well and then mentally for
me fell off on Vancouver second and third
goal you're right though sh Carolina has
tightened up the game here in this second
period now McKinnon he'll drop it back for
Gerard that'll be hammered by ran and lose
pu R gets across on thein here but right now
ATI R welcome to this one to sa swatted at it
Carolina was able to get it out of the zone and
now chipped up for Bunning from warlock Bunning
he's got a lane bunny goes in sends it across
shot Z goria pck still loose oh what a chance
for Carolina on McKinnon other way bunny has a
chance to set this one up orl love robbed by G
now terraining with it 27 seconds left on the
man Advantage AO to burns down low terrain
terrain works it this one they score on the
power play Michael bunny Tic Tac table on the
pass again and Bunting has put Carolina into
a two goal lead it's 42 hurricanes this is a
professor like from terrain watch what he does
here to reach around ma go from his forehand to
first of all taking it off the skate but
it's not there ma stick was in the lane
on one side of Ma so he in the most crafty
fashion goes around the other side bunting
beats periz to the net and beats the goal
tender clean Ki findes n he tries to bounce
that out front but the loose Puck is going
to be skating away now here comes Colorado
trailer and black it ins k r in making that
type of change and I think it's instrumental
in where this game is at we just showed you
the numbers how good aunti R has been with
the hurricanes in his career and now here comes
an opportunity and that's rung off the post by
McKinnon it doesn't get through to gorg EV and and
Manson will clear this one d'angel has played just
under 10 minutes he's been solid a chance and in
a big save coach jov on Gerard with the glove now
Colorado keeping the pressure on circling the net
now back to top Manson's drive that's blocked by
Lemieux Gerard to it he send it out for Co the PO
and then a huge save pu still loose on all of Co C
scrambling it's under his skates no whistle yet no
whistle yet now we finally get one that's going to
be good oh he'll win it back Burns shuttle it over
AO with a shot and that hit the post Sebastian AO
looking for his 19th of the season and he'll get
it to the bumper a chance there for first side
of the net it'll be poked out by JIS he couldn't
settle it down and gorv will make the save since
then facing a ton of lead power play Carolina's
power play has been the better in those matchups
a chance of r on gorv makes the save he tied up o'
Conor now Bunny inside of the net Jarvis shuffles
one out in front AO whacks that second opportunity
gorgia makes the save mckinon throws it behind
the net n ronu back to the point captain in by
McKinnon deflected up for ketov with a huge pad
save kicking out the left Pell pinch that along
the board that'll come free for McKinnon but he
lose it now go for he's going to play it off the
cours Jarvis has it empty net Ron comes back but
he's going to take a penalty I think you a a goal
here I think he might I thought he was he was you
could argue he was in the act of shooting I think
he wore the goal table again a nice play with
three assists tonight yeah you could argue he's in
the in the process of finishing this thing on the
backand the calling the ice is an award a
goal due to a foul and a breakaway Chatfield
with it good exchange here of the puck
chadfield he'll drop it back KMI through
traffic it hits the post and then gorev
with 1.9 seconds left probably found out
Midway through the afternoon he was going to
play and he and Chad feel very s what a win
that's it they dro the P the horn sounds
and the Hurricanes take a 5-2 win tonight